good morning the Norwegian Nobel
Committee has decided to award the Nobel
Peace Prize for 2018 to Denis McCrea
and Nadya Murad for their efforts to end
the use of sexual violence as a weapon
of war an armed conflict both laureates
have made a crucial contribution to
focusing attention on and combating such
war crimes Denis Makaha is the helper
who has devoted his life to defending
these victims now the arm Murad is the
witness who tells of the abuses
perpetrated against herself and others
each of them in their own ways has
helped to give greater visibility to
wartime sexual violence so that the
perpetrators can be held accountable for
their actions the physician Denis
McGregor has spent large parts of his
adult life helping victims of sexual
violence in the Democratic Republic of
Congo since the poncey hospital was
established in Bukavu in 2008 dr.
McGregor and his staff have treated
thousands of patients who have fallen
victims to such assaults most of the
abuses have been committed in the
context of a long-lasting civil war that
has cost the lives of more than 6
million Congolese
Denis McGregor is the foremost most
unifying symbol both nationally and
internationally of the struggle to end
sexual violence in war and armed
conflict his basic principle is that
justice is everyone's business men and
women officers and soldiers local
national and international authorities
alike all have a shared responsibility
for reporting and combating this type of
war crime the importance of Denis
mukwege is enduring dedicated and
selfless efforts in this field cannot be
overrated he has repeatedly condemned
impunity for mass rape and criticized
the Congolese government and other
countries for not doing enough to stop
the use of sexual violence against women
as a strategy and a weapon of war
Nadia Murad is herself a victim of war
crimes she refused to accept the social
codes that required women to remain
silent and ashamed of the abuses to
which they had been subjected she has
shown uncommon courage in recounting her
own suffering and speaking up on behalf
of other victims
Nadia Murad is a member of the Yazidi
minority in northern Iraq where she
lived with her family in the remote
village of kocho in August 2014 the
Islamic state Isis launched a brutal
systematic attack on the villages of the
Sinjar region
aimed at exterminating they are seedy
population in Nadia Murad's village
several hundred people were massacred
the younger women including underage
children were abducted and held as sex
slaves
while the captive of the ISIS Nadia
Murad was repeatedly subjected to rape
and other abuses her assault is
threatened to execute her if she did not
convert to their hateful in human
version of Islam
Nadia Murad is just one of an estimated
3,000 year city girls and women who were
victims of rape and other abuses by the
Isis army the abuses were systematic and
part of a military strategy thus they
served as weapon in the fight against
your CDs and other religious minorities
after a three-month nightmare Nadia
Murad managed to flee following her
escape she chose to speak openly about
what she had endured and in 2016 at the
age of just 23
she was named the UN's first goodwill
ambassador for the dignity of survivors
of human trafficking this year marks a
decade since the UN Secretary Council
excuse me UN Security Council adopted
resolution 1820 which determined that
the use of sexual violence as a weapon
of war and armed conflict constitutes
both a war crime and a threat to
international peace and security
this is also set out in the Rome status
of 1998 which governs the work of the
International Criminal Court the statue
establishes that sexual violence in war
and armed conflict is a grave violation
of international law a more peaceful
world can only be achieved if women and
their fundamental rights and security
are recognized and protected in war this
year's Nobel Prize Peace Prize is firmly
embedded in the criteria spelled out in
Alfred Nobel's will Dennis McGregor and
Nadia Murat have both put their personal
security at risk by courageously
combating war crimes and seeking justice
for victims they have thereby promoted
the fraternity of nations through the
application of principles of
international law thank you very much
the most important message you want to
send out to the world bar this year's
Nobel Peace Prize we want to send out a
message of awareness that women who
constitute half of the population in
most communities actually are used as a
weapon of war and that they need
protection and that the perpetrators
have to be prosecuted and held
responsible for their actions we believe
that this is a fundamental prerequisite
for lasting peace to also include the
rights and the awareness of women madam
chair congratulations you're supposed to
give the prize to the ones who have
contributed the most to peace in the
last year why this price this year this
year and Nadia Murad has spoken up on
abuses against women it is a price web
it won't cannot single out that it is
one particular event this year it has
been a continuous development in efforts
from the United Nations efforts by brave
individuals and as we stand here in the
year of 2018 we see that dr. Denis
mukwege and Nadia Murad carried this
message in the most efficient way in the
previous year committee in any way
indirectly being inspired also by the
media movement and sexual assaults on
women in general well I believe there is
that me too and war crimes is not quite
the same thing but I do have ever have
that in common
that
it is important for to see the suffering
of women to see the abuses and to
achieve that it is also important that
women leave the concept of shame and
speak up have you been in contact with
any of the winners and what were their
reactions we have tried to contact the
winners and we haven't managed to get
through on the phone if they are
watching this my heartfelt
congratulations yes my name is Viviana
Pina I represent a Norwegian news agency
Denis Makua has been on the noble
shortlist for about 10 years
what is the reason he made it this time
and in in choosing between 331
candidates or the almost record high
number what were the main challenges in
finding a unified decision well first of
all I cannot comment on who has been on
the committee's shortlist we are
instructed by the will of Alfred Nobel
not to speak about our deliberations we
only communicate to you who has actually
been found worthy of receiving the prize
each year and then I can really just
reply your question by stating again
that taking this subject into
consideration highlighting the
importance of the subject we found that
these two individuals in a most
significant way have actually been vocal
on this subject that is of course not to
say that there are other individuals
other efforts who also address this
subject and they also need they deserve
thanks and recognition but with this
price we recognize the two individuals
that we believe have been in front of
this
cause that's Madame chair my name is
unlimited yo Norway or that I'd rather
not again
sexual violence has been debated a lot
over the past year how important has
that been in your decision
well sexual violence has been debated
the lost in the past year in the context
of what should we say civil society and
how men and women interact in our
society in particular in the workplace
because this is I understand where Alisa
me to question but as I have highlighted
and the reasons I already have given
already in the Roman statues of 1998
both genocide and crimes against
humanity is defined can take place by
using women and sexual abuse or for that
matter sexual abuse against men as an
instrument so this is not a new concept
in international thinking however not so
very old and the UN secure the the UN
has followed up by several resolutions
on this area and we can say it has been
a development to abuse against women
sexual abuse against women at war time
is a well-known phenomena it's not the
phenomena of our time but it has been a
development to make it an issue of
politics and the business of the
international community to recognize it
and take responsibility for the issue
now the other table is a member of the
genetic ethnic group and it seems like
wars that are ethnic are especially
violent in a way was there ever any
plans of discussions of having a third
winner this year from the Rohingyas
again I have to underline we cannot tell
you about
our deliberations this is the conclusion
we came to but the point that you raised
that we the what we raise here is we say
women are particularly vulnerable to
sexual abuse in war but also belonging
to a minority you are particularly
vulnerable in war so there may be many
factors but what we are addressing by
this year's price is the situation of
women in wartime and other armed
conflicts
what what are your hopes for an eventual
impact of this price on sexual violence
in worse when we say the purpose is
partly to highlight the awareness of
sexual abuse and the further purpose of
that is that nations take responsibility
that communities take responsibility and
that the international community takes
responsibility and what is very
important is not that we just say this
is criminal behavior but that we
actually act and prosecute the
perpetrators and that incidents are
reported of course the final goal is to
end the crime and also to end the
impunity
Loret ever I believe so Malala yousufzai
is so far the youngest thank you very
much thank you